my fellow Americans
[Applause]
Michelle and I have been so touched by
all the well wishes that we've received
over the past few weeks but tonight
tonight it's my turn to say things
whether we have seen eye to eye or
really agreed at all my conversations
with you the American people in living
rooms and in schools that farms on
factory floors diners and on distant
military outposts those conversations
are what have kept me honest
and kept me inspired and kept me going
and every day I have learned from you
you made me a better president and you
made me a better man so I first came to
Chicago when I was in my early 20s and I
was still trying to figure out who I was
still searching for a purpose in my life
and it was a neighborhood not far from
here where I began working with church
groups and the shadows of close steel
mills it was on these streets where I
witnessed the power of faith and the
quiet dignity of working people in the
face of struggle and loss
I can't do that
now this is where I learned the change
only happens when ordinary people get
involved and they get engaged and they
come together to demand it after eight
years as your president I still believe
that and it's not just my belief it's
the beating heart of our American idea
our bold experiment in self-government
it's the conviction that we are all
created equal endowed by our creator
with certain inalienable rights among
them life liberty and the pursuit of
happiness
it's the insistence that these rights
while self-evident have never been
self-executing
that we the people through the
instrument of our democracy can form a
more perfect union what a radical idea
the great gift that our founders gave to
us the freedom to chase our individual
dreams through our sweat and toil and
imagination and the imperative to strive
together as well to achieve a common
good a greater good for 240 years our
nation's call to citizenship has given
work and purpose to each new generation
it's what led Patriots to choose
Republic over tyranny pioneers to trek
west slaves to brave that makeshift
railroad to freedom it's what pulled
immigrants and refugees across oceans
than the Rio Grande
it's what pushed women to reach for the
ballot it's what powered workers to
organize
that's why GIS gave their lives of Omaha
Beach and Iwo Jima Iraq and Afghanistan
and why men and women from Selma to
stonewall were prepared to give theirs
as well so
so that's what we mean when we say
America is exceptional not that our
nation's been flawless from the start
but that we have shown the capacity to
change and make life better for those
who follow yes
our progress has been uneven the work of
democracy has always been hard it's
always been contentious sometimes it's
been bloody for every two steps forward
it often feels we take one step back but
the long sweep of America has been
defined by forward motion a constant
widening of our founding Creed to
embrace all and not just some
if i have told you eight years ago that
america would reverse a Great Recession
reboot our auto industry and unleash the
longest stretch of job creation in our
history if I had told you that we would
open up a new chapter with the Cuban
people shut down Iran's nuclear weapons
program without firing a shot
take out the mastermind of 9/11 if I
have told you that we would win marriage
equality and secure
for another 20 million of our fellow
citizens
if I told y'all that you might have said
our sights were set a little too high
but that's what we did that's what you
did
you were the change the answer people's
hopes and because of you by almost every
measure America is a better stronger
place than it was when we started
in ten days the world will witness a
hallmark of our democracy whoa no no no
no the peaceful transfer of power from
one freely elected President to the next
I committed to president-elect Trump
that my administration would ensure the
smoothest possible transition just as
President Bush did for me because
it's up to all of us to make sure our
government can help us meet the many
challenges we still face we have what we
need to do so we have everything we need
to meet those challenges after all we
remain the wealthiest most powerful and
most respected nation on earth
our youth our drive our diversity and
openness are boundless capacity for risk
and reinvention means that the future
should be our stream but that potential
will only be realized if our democracy
works only if our politics better
reflects the decency of our people only
if all of us
regardless of party affiliation or
particular interests help restore the
sense of common purpose that we so badly
need right now and that's what I want to
focus on tonight
the state of our democracy understand
democracy does not require uniformity
our founders argued they quarreled
eventually they compromised they
expected us to do the same but they knew
that democracy does require a basic
sense of solidarity the idea that for
all our outward differences we're all in
this together that we rise or fall as
one
there have been moments throughout our
history that threatened that solidarity
and the beginning of this century has
been one of those times a shrinking
world growing inequality demographic
change and the specter of terrorism
these forces haven't just tested our
security and our prosperity but our
testing our democracy as well and how we
meet these challenges to our democracy
will determine our ability to educate
our kids and create good jobs and
protect our homelands in other words it
will determine our future to begin with
our democracy won't work without a sense
that everyone has Economic Opportunity
and the good news is that today the
economy is growing again wages incomes
home values and retirement cuts are all
rising again poverty is falling again
the wealthy are paying a fair share of
taxes even as the stock market shatters
records the unemployment rate is near a
ten-year level the uninsured rate has
never ever been lower
health care costs are rising at the
slowest rate in 50 years and I've said
and I mean it if anyone can put together
a plan that is demonstrably better than
the approvement we've made to our health
care system that covers as many people
at less cost
I will publicly support
because that after all is why we serve
[Applause]
not to score points or take credit but
to make people's lives better but for
all the real progress that we've made we
know it's not enough our economy doesn't
work as well or grow as fast when a few
prosper at the expense of a growing
middle class and ladders for folks who
want to get into the middle class that's
the economic argument but Stark
inequality is also corrosive to our
democratic idea while the top one
percent has amassed a bigger share of
wealth and income to many of our
families in inner cities and in rural
counties have been left behind the laid
off factory worker the waitress or
health care worker who's just barely
getting by and struggling to pay the
bills convinced that the game is fixed
against them that their government only
serves the interests of the powerful
that's a recipe for more cynicism and
polarization in our politics now there
are no quick fixes to this long-term
trend
I agree our trade should be fair and not
just free but the next wave of economic
dislocations won't come from overseas it
will come from the relentless pace of
automation that makes a lot of good
middle-class jobs obsolete and so we're
going to have to forge a new social
compact to guarantee all our kids the
education they need to to give workers
the power to unionize for better wages
to update the social safety net to
reflect the way we live now and make
more reforms to the tax codes or
corporations and individuals who reap
the most from this new economy don't
avoid their obligations to the country
that's made their very success possible
we can argue about how to best achieve
these goals but we can't be complacent
about the goals themselves for if we
don't create opportunity for all people
the disaffection
and division that is stalled our
progress will only sharpen in years to
come there's a second threat to our
democracy and this one is as old as our
nation itself after my election there
was talk of a post-racial America and
such a vision however well intended was
never realistic race remains a potent
and often divisive force in our society
now I've lived long enough to know that
race relations are better than they were
ten or twenty or thirty years ago no
matter what some folks say you can see
it
not just in statistics you see it in the
attitudes of young Americans across the
political spectrum but we're not where
we need to be and all of us have more
work to do if every economic issue is
framed as a struggle between a
hard-working white middle class and an
undeserving minority then workers of all
shades are going to be left fighting for
scraps while the wealthy withdraw
further into their private Enclave
if we're unwilling to invest in the
children of immigrants just because they
don't look like us we will diminish the
prospects of our own children because
those brown kids will represent a larger
and larger share of America's workforce
and we have shown that our economy
doesn't have to be a zero-sum game last
year incomes rose for all races all age
groups for men and for women
so if we're going to be serious about
race going forward we need to uphold
laws against discrimination in hiring
and in housing and in education and in
the criminal justice system that is what
our Constitution and our highest ideals
required but laws alone won't be enough
parts must change it won't change
overnight Social Attitudes oftentimes
take generations to change but if our
democracy is to work the way it should
in this increasingly diverse nation then
each one of us need to try to heed the
advice of a great character in American
fiction Atticus Finch who said you never
really understand a person until you
consider things from his point of view
until you climb into his skin and walk
around in it for blacks and other
minority groups that means tying our own
very real struggles for justice to the
challenges that a lot of people in this
country face not only the refugee or the
immigrant or the rural poor or the
transgender American but also the
middle-aged white guy who from the
outside may seem like he's got
advantages but has seen his world
upended by economic and cultural and
technological change we have to pay
attention and listen
for white Americans it means
acknowledging that the effects of
slavery and Jim Crow didn't suddenly
vanish in the 60s but when minority
groups voice discontent they're not just
engaging in reverse racism or practicing
political correctness when they wage
peaceful protests they're not demanding
special treatment but the equal
treatment that our founders promised
the native-born Americans
for native-born Americans it means
reminding ourselves that the stereotypes
about immigrants today were said almost
word-for-word about the Irish and
Italians and poles who it was said were
going to destroy the fundamental
character of America and as it turned
out America wasn't weakened by the
presidents of these newcomers these
newcomers embraced this nation's Creed
and this nation was strengthened so
regardless of the station that we occupy
we all have to try harder we all have to
start with the premise that each of our
fellow citizens loves this country just
as much as we do that they value hard
work and family just like we do that
their children are just as curious and
hopeful and worthy of love as our own
and that's not easy to do for too many
of us it's become safer to retreat into
our own bubbles whether in our
neighborhoods or on college campuses or
places of worship or especially our
social media feeds surrounded by people
who look like us and share the same
political outlook and never challenged
our assumptions in the rise of naked
partisanship and increasing economic and
regional stratification the splitting of
our media into a channel for every taste
all this makes this great sorting seem
natural even inevitable and increasingly
we become so secure in our bubbles that
we start accepting only information
whether it's true or not that fits our
opinions instead of basing our opinions
on the evidence that is out there
and this trend represents a third threat
to our democracy but politics is a
battle of ideas that's how our democracy
was designed in the course of a healthy
debate we prioritize different goals and
the different means of reaching them but
without some common baseline of facts
without a willingness to admit new
information and concede that your
opponent might be making a fair point
and that science and reason matter then
we're going to keep talking past each
other and we'll make common ground and
compromise impossible and isn't that
part of what so often makes politics
dispirited
how can elected officials rage about
deficits when we propose to spend money
on preschool for kids but not when we're
cutting taxes for corporations how do we
excuse after the lapses in our own party
but pounce when the other party does the
same thing it's not just dishonest this
selective sorting of the facts it's
self-defeating because as my mom used to
tell me reality has a way of catching up
with
[Applause]
take the challenge of climate change in
just eight years we've halved our
dependence on foreign oil we doubled our
renewable energy we've led the world to
an agreement that has the promise to
save this planet
but without vulgar action our children
won't have time to debate the existence
of climate change they'll be busy
dealing with its effects more
environmental disasters more economic
disruptions waves of climate refugees
seeking sanctuary now we we can and
should argue about the best approach to
solve the problem but to simply deny the
problem not only betrays future
generations it betrays the essential
spirit of this country the essential
spirit of innovation and practical
problem-solving that guided our founders
it is that spirit it is that spirit born
of the Enlightenment that made us an
economic powerhouse the spirit that took
flight at Kitty Hawk and Cape Canaveral
the spirit that cures disease and put a
computer in every pocket it's that
spirit of faith in reason and enterprise
and the primacy of right over mic that
allowed us to resist the lure of fascism
and tyranny during the Great Depression
that allowed us to build a post-world
War two order with other democracies an
order based not just on military power
or national affiliations but built on
principles the rule of law human rights
freedom of religion and speech and
assembly and an independent press
that order is now being challenged first
by violent fanatics who claim to speak
for Islam more recently by autocrats in
foreign capitals who see free markets
and open democracies and civil society
itself as a threat to their power the
peril each poses to our democracy is
more far-reaching than a car bomb or a
missile
they represent the fear of change the
fear of people who look or speak or pray
differently a contempt for the rule of
law that holds leaders accountable an
intolerance of dissent and free thought
the belief that the sword or the gun or
the bomb or the propaganda machine is
the ultimate arbiter of what's true and
what's right
because of the extraordinary courage of
our men and women in uniform because of
our intelligence officers and law
enforcement and diplomats who support
our troops
no foreign terrorist organization has
successfully planned and executed an
attack on our homeland these past eight
years
and although Boston in Orlando and San
Bernardino and Fort Hood remind us of
how dangerous radicalization can be our
law enforcement agencies are more
effective and vigilant than ever we have
taken out tens of thousands of
terrorists including bin Laden the
global coalition were leading against
ISIL has taken out their leaders and
taken away about half their territory
ISIL will be destroyed and no one who
threatens America will ever be safe and
all who serve or have served it has been
the honor of my lifetime to be your
commander-in-chief
but protecting our way of life that's
not just the job of our military
democracy can buckle when it gives in to
fear so just as we as citizens must
remain vigilant against external
aggression we must guard against a
weakening of the values that make us who
we are and that's why for the past eight
years I've worked to put the fight
against terrorism on a firmer legal
footing
that's why we've ended tortured work to
close Gitmo reformed our laws governing
surveillance to protect privacy and
civil liberties that's why I reject
discrimination against Muslim Americans
who are distant patriotic as
that's why we cannot withdraw that's why
we cannot withdraw from big global
fights to expand democracy and human
rights and women's rights in LGBT rights
no matter how imperfect our efforts no
matter how expedient ignoring such
values may seem that's part of defending
America for the fight against extremism
and intolerance and sectarianism and
chauvinism are of a piece with the fight
against authoritarianism and nationalist
aggression if the scope of freedom and
respect for the rule of law shrinks
around the world the likelihood of war
within and between nations increases and
our own freedoms will eventually be
threatened so let's be vigilant but not
afraid ISIL will try to kill innocent
people
but they cannot defeat America unless we
betray our Constitution and our
principles in the fight
rivals like Russia or China cannot match
our influence around the world unless we
give up what we stand for and turn
ourselves into just another big country
that bullies smaller neighbors which
brings me to my final point our
democracy our democracy is threatened
whenever we take it for granted all of
us
regardless of party should be throwing
ourselves into the task of rebuilding
our democratic institutions when voting
rates in America are some of the lowest
among advanced democracies we should be
making it easier not harder to vote
when
then trust
institutions is low we should reduce the
corrosive influence of money in our
politics and insist on the principles of
transparency and ethics in public
service when Congress is dysfunctional
we should draw our congressional
districts to encourage politicians to
cater to common sense and not rigid
extremes
but remember none of this happens on its
own all of this depends on our
participation on each of us accepting
the responsibility of citizenship
regardless of which way the pendulum of
power happens to be swinging it our
Constitution is a remarkable beautiful
gift but it's really just a piece of
parchment it has no power on its own we
the people give it power we the people
give it meaning with our participation
and with the choices that we make and
the Alliance is what we Forge whether or
not we stand up for our freedoms whether
or not we respect and enforce the rule
of law that's up to us America is no
fragile thing but the gains of our long
journey to freedom are not assured in
his own farewell address George
Washington wrote that self-government is
the underpinning of our safety
prosperity and liberty but
from different causes and from different
quarters much pains will be taken to
weaken in your minds the conviction of
this truth and so we have to preserve
this truth with jealous anxiety that we
should reject the first dawning of every
attempt to alienate any portion of our
country from the rest or to enfeeble the
sacred ties that make us one
America we weaken those ties when we
allow our political dialogue to become
so corrosive the people of good
character aren't even willing to enter
into public service so course with
rancor the Americans with whom we
disagree are seen not just as misguided
but as malevolent we weaken those ties
when we define some of us as more
American than others when we write off
the whole system as inevitably corrupt
and when we sit back and blame the
leaders we elect without examining our
own role in electing them
it falls to each of us to be those
anxious jealous guardians of our
democracy to embrace the joyous task
we've been given to continually try to
improve this great nation of ours
because for all our outward differences
we in fact all share the same proud
title the most important office in a
democracy citizen
so you see that's what our democracy
demands it needs you not just when
there's an election not just when your
own narrow interests is at stake but
over the full span of a lifetime if
you're tired of arguing with strangers
on the Internet
try talking with one of them in real
life
if something needs fixing then lace up
your shoes and do some organizing if
you're disappointed by your elected
officials grab a clipboard get some
signatures and run for office yourself
slow up dive in stay at it sometimes
you'll win sometimes you lose
presuming a reservoir of goodness and
other people that can be a risk and
there will be times when the process
will disappoint you but for those of us
fortunate enough to have been part of
this work and to see it up close let me
tell you it can energize and inspire and
more often than not your faith in
America and in Americans will be
confirmed mine sure has been over the
course of these eight years
I've seen the hopeful faces of young
graduates and our newest military
officers I have mourned with grieving
families searching for answers and found
grace in Charleston Church I've seen our
scientists help a paralyzed man regain
his sense of touch I've seen wounded
warriors who at points were given up for
dead walk again I've seen our doctors
and volunteers rebuild after earthquakes
and stop pandemics in their tracks I've
seen the youngest of children remind us
through their actions and through their
generosity of our obligations to care
for Refugees or work for peace and above
all to look out for each other
so that faith that I placed all those
years ago
not far from here in the power of
ordinary Americans to bring about change
that faith has been rewarded in ways I
could not have possibly imagined and I
hope your faith has to some of you here
tonight or watching at home you were
there with us in 2004 2008 2012
maybe you still can't believe we pulled
this whole thing off
let me tuck you're not the only ones
Michelle
[Applause]
Michelle Lebon Robinson girl of the
South said
for the fat for the past 25 years you
have not only been my wife and mother of
my children you have been my best friend
you took on a role you didn't ask for
and you made it your own with grace and
with grit and the style and humor
we made the White House a place that
belongs to everybody and a new
generation sets its sights higher
because it has you as a role model so
you have made me proud and you have made
the country proud
Malia and Sasha under the strangest of
circumstances you have become two
amazing young women you are smart and
you are beautiful but more importantly
you are kind and you are thoughtful and
you are full of passion
you're the burden of years in the
spotlight so easily of all that I have
done in my life
I am most proud to be your dad
to Joe Biden
[Applause]
favorite son you were the first decision
I made as a nominee and it was the best
not just because you have been a great
vice president but because in the
bargain I gained a brother and we love
you and Jill like family and your
friendship has been one of the great
joys of our less
to my remarkable staff for 80 years
and for some of you a whole lot more I
have drawn from your energy and every
day I tried to reflect back what you
displayed heart and character and
idealism I've watched you grow up
get married have kids start incredible
new journeys of your your own even when
times got tough and frustrating you
never let Washington get the better of
you you guard it against cynicism and
the only thing that makes me prouder
than all the good that we've done is the
thought of all the amazing things that
you are going to achieve from here
and all of you out there every organizer
who moved to an unfamiliar town every
kind family who welcomed them in every
volunteer who knocked on doors every
young person who cast a ballot for the
first time every American who lived and
breathed the hard work of change you are
the best supporters and organizers
anybody could ever hope for and I will
be forever grateful because you did
change the world you did and that's why
I leave this stage tonight even more
optimistic about this country than when
we started because I know our work has
not only helped so many Americans it has
inspired so many Americans especially so
many young people out there to believe
that you can make a difference to hitch
your wagon to something bigger than
yourselves let me tell you this
generation coming up unselfish
altruistic creative patriotic I've seen
you in every corner of the country you
believe in a fair and just an inclusive
America you know the constant change has
been America's hallmark
not something to fear but something to
embrace you are willing to carry this
hard work of democracy quote you'll soon
outnumber all of us and I believe as a
result the futures in good hands
my fellow Americans it has been the
honor of my life to serve you I won't
stop in fact I will be right there with
you as a citizen for all my remaining
days but for now whether you are young
or whether you're young at heart I do
have one final ask of you as your
president the same thing I asked when
you took a chance on me eight years ago
I'm asking you to believe not in my
ability to bring about change but in
yours I'm asking you to hold fast to
that faith written into our founding
documents that idea whispered by slaves
and abolitionists that spirit sung by
immigrants and homesteaders and those
who marched for justice that Creed
reaffirmed by those who planted flags
from foreign battlefields to the surface
of the Moon a Creed at the core of every
American whose story is not yet written
yes we can
god bless you
you